it's so [ __ ] like the editors are
geniuses they are do you and I have been
on Megan rinks his podcast
oh no Megan who's this a youtuber she
was on my podcast - she she was on your
mind she's a sweetie yeah Nikki was also
on it on her snake it was really nice
super super fun so she has been making
headlines recently because of the fact
that her main I believe it's her main
YouTube channel her vlog channel her
blog Channel okay her vlog channel has
been hacked and completely rebranded oh
you guys know her yeah to be like this
completely other different channel this
is Megan she couldn't call YouTube and
say YouTube can you help me girl you
need to watch this 45-minute video it's
so entertaining
yeah with a [ __ ] I don't even know who
she is well she's she's making okay
she's dope okay super dope
she has more subs than you [ __ ] on
her I mean that was 2 million
she's know who you are Bart hurting
feelings man she knows who I am
she literally does yeah oh and so this
is what she ended up tweeting after
months by the way after months of her
trying to reach YouTube and true pretty
much talking to bots and she has like
her lawyers her managers like all these
people on these emails because for
months before she tweeted this out she
had been trying to get YouTube to like
[ __ ] fix this [ __ ] someone really
hacked in we bring [ __ ] yeah so crazy
not just Randy but like [ __ ] hardcore
yeah everything like uploads completely
locked her out of all her email accounts
that were like the secondary accounts
and all the videos and she's actively
fighting it too during that and they
still didn't help her yeah they're like
let me see no evidence exactly so then
she ends up sweetie are you kidding me
YouTube creators my channel was hacked
rebranded and they're uploading contact
content of what the [ __ ] and this is
what they said they said in the email I
understand why you're wondering that the
investigation resulted that no hijacking
activity happened on the channel however
I can't assure you that our internal
team carefully investigated this and
didn't found any yeah nice
Indian call center maybe so this is her
channel now if you can you can see up
here on the URL it says more Megan and
its beauty dior with five hundred and
six thousand subscribers would you want
her subscribers and they have completely
stolen content oh this channel oh wow
yeah and so with that scare you with the
help of Shane actually cuz she liked
what we did it and like thanks to shame
that's when you two finally gave a [ __ ]
about but that's what's [ __ ] up is you
have to go viral with your with your
[ __ ] outrage yeah she has been saying
that there have been so many other small
creators are like screaming into the
void trying to contact YouTube saying
that this exact same problem has
happened to them YouTube's not doing
[ __ ] I mean they don't have a partner
relations person that can just go well
that sushi needs a contact like she's
been trying to like be one-on-one with
also she didn't have a like a live human
being that's what she thought she had on
a small scale it's the American health
care system right right hey I got a
GoFundMe to help fund my my [ __ ] I got a
real problem I hope it goes viral
it's really like unless you are like top
tier [ __ ] YouTube con she has half a
million two million two million to write
the top tiers got to be like 2030
million to and then this one was a half
a million so originally her main channel
got hacked Wow and that quickly got
resolved but then she didn't know that
they had also also gotten all the
information for her second channel which
later one of her followers found in a
hack forum site that her channel was up
for sale for $500 why did she buy it
well she was like [ __ ] if I would have
known that I would have bought it myself
but she didn't know information why did
they try to sell it to her for more I
don't know damn YouTube is not helpful
though I don't know dude I got [ __ ]
to monetize and there's no Avenue it's
like you're [ __ ] you're demonetized
[ __ ] you but not even your network could
help you no no they told me to delete 65
my videos are you serious yeah they're
like here here's what we think you
should do maybe if you delete 65 of your
most popular videos that then they'll
let you be monetized
again and I'm like [ __ ] you guys I don't
care that's my history [ __ ] you I like
this why is that in the for Megan's case
it's really really [ __ ] up because the
last update that I know of is that
YouTube said okay we can give you back
your channel but in order for us to do
that you and this is after so many back
and forth swear and didn't know where
it's really frustrating if you watch her
video finally they end up getting to
this conclusion that says we can give
you back your channel but everything
that is private 'add will be deleted but
you have to before we give you your
channel you have to confirm which is
Megan that this content is your content
YouTube you have a basis on it you
stupid [ __ ] it's ridiculous no no no
it's not her face is not her [ __ ]
she can't claim that they took it away
Dolan oh they put [ __ ] weird like
Beauty lips [ __ ] on it and yeah like so
they're telling her to claim the content
that isn't her how she gonna do that she
can ad it running that department like
what's happening I thought these guys
were really [ __ ] smart so the thing
is it seems to be that a lot of bots are
doing the jobs for humans and the bots
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
and then YouTube seems to have
outsourced to customer service - yeah
and so hence here we are and what sucks
is now she has spent thousands of
thousands of dollars on lawyers to just
get her own [ __ ] back that's rightfully
hers well it makes no sense right
because her Channel if it's two point
something million and she's probably
generating like millions of revenue
right that means if YouTube's taking 40%
of that they're making millions off of
her and they're gonna give her that [ __ ]
customer service it's they're making
billions but so they don't give a [ __ ]
for her for for them she's not even a
percentage of their business model so
they're like who gives a [ __ ] we don't
literally care where that's why we're
gonna outsource a whole division or
whatever that's why you can't get
customer service at YouTube have you
ever been able to talk to anybody at
YouTube it's very rare well we had we
just have our network talk to somebody
all right
oh why do you have to have a network
because we can't count on talking to you
because I don't want to I don't want an
hour crowd your people have given away
huge percentages of the YouTube revenue
because they just want to be able to
talk to YouTube to resolve simple
[ __ ] issues
that they can't so true this video she
did the 45-minute video I'm talking
about technically is 44 minutes whatever
this was uploaded three days ago and
that's the video that Shane had quote
tweeted which finally got her some
attention with YouTube and so she got on
a call and on her Twitter she was saying
like oh I got on a call and then update
it did not go well and like a screenshot
of her face like crying so we don't know
where she has been left at this point
that's up let me tell you what happened
so I have been on call with YouTube many
times the other I used to be on some
kind of a [ __ ] program with like its
creators access you know we we care
about what you guys think so all they do
if you if you bump them off their script
all they do is jump back on their script
because they have no idea how to [ __ ]
they're not there to solve anything
they're just there to assuage your
feelings me is it an Indian call center
this person was not particularly that I
think they have since I met just like
three years ago I think they have since
just downloaded all the way to Indian
call center cuz they don't give I don't
give a [ __ ] they didn't give a [ __ ] then
they don't give a [ __ ] now they my
person then I was like hey how come when
you guys algorithmically change things
you don't like let your top creators
know that so that we can move with you
guys and like and they're like oh thank
you know well they don't even know
what's what I want no I know why they
don't tell the creators because they're
catering to the big networks
that's all they want that's true they
want like YouTube is the new television
they don't want small creators anymore
yeah I agree
no and you can tell because of the way
that they push related if you look in
related they're almost always pushing
some kind of a mainstream media group
like somebody like big usually Viacom
own whatever Jimmy Kimmel or so we just
need to become like a BuzzFeed do it not
even then it has to be like network
owned and thank you so let's see what
BuzzFeed's pretty pretty closer they're
going for this there's a lot of digital
guys that moved over like VC money in
their ya know like you said Jimmy
Kimmel's on everything is in related tax
and everything I see a lot of MSNBC Fox
News CNN on everything like they don't
push tubers they push old school [ __ ]
and is it probably because of the money
because I don't know what do you think
happened right so the whole thing that
happened with Coppa and a lot of this
other stuff is that people were going
hey who the [ __ ] all these youtubers
what videos are they making this is
crazy
we can rely on the old-school
traditional models sell ads because you
don't have to worry about what kind of
content they're making so we'll just go
back to that and that's what I'm talking
about eating the booty and all the
things that matter to people too but
then at the same time when the copis had
happen and like all the kid-friendly
channels got like their comments removed
and like demonetized i was like oh [ __ ]
for the first time me talk about eating
booty for years paid off you know i'm
saying cuz i'm not a a kid channel
couple years ago we were like oh we
should have been pc yeah and we should
have been like we should have been good
dude I had bad words and do the kid
channel [ __ ] I had a buddy who laughed
when I got to monetized and he's like
you know I get it's fine you can laugh
it about anything he was like you know I
get it cuz like advertisers don't really
want to advertise for that stuff and I
was like just wait till happens to you
because he was making kid cotton mm-hm
and now it has in a major way yeah
that's all I'm saying like it's just
frustrating cuz YouTube is not a great
place to to run a business it's a
horrible place for a business that's why
we all need patreon to survive mmm it's
changed a lot for us yeah we lost we
were making a third of what we used to
people have to just keep changing their
business model I think we have to keep
evolving and that's just business but it
sucks because it comes abruptly I think
that they suck at communication mmm they
don't care to communicate they don't
yeah I bet you Ryan from Ryan's toy
reviews like he's making so much money I
know right but 26 million last year I
know
PewDiePie feels the warm embrace of
YouTube he's the biggest critic exactly
yeah there you go he's still making
crazy money though sure yeah I mean all
of them right like if any of
Paradis was actually caught up the
amount of views that youtubers can bring
to something like versus radio and TV is
[ __ ] massive and the fact that we get
paid $1 to every [ __ ] $50.00 that
those guys get paid or more is nuts it
is pretty crazy because people don't
really know that they take 40 something
percent of the ad revenue
hmm and and the ad revenues is already
on my new show of what they get on TV
and radio and radio doesn't even [ __ ]
touch what he used to touch but it's
gonna go up though eventually we're just
at the early early stages yeah where as
a business you know it's it's we're
getting premium on the [ __ ] dollar
right now if you advertise on YouTube
Google Adsense if you do Facebook
Instagram Vogue man people are missing
out dude we're [ __ ] it up for sure
but I aren't radio which is the biggest
[ __ ] radio conglomerate in the world
in the world right now they filed for
bankruptcy recently so yeah so what does
that tell you right and those guys are
still getting the [ __ ] ton of money to
run ads so when's our gonna catch up man
when are we gonna we're gonna not need
patreon this [ __ ] and survive we just
gotta keep surviving until it moves into
this space exactly subscribe to the
patreon guys so thank you for
subscribing to the patriarchy eyes you
keep us online McDonald's if only who
understood that when we talk about
eating the booty it helps your Papa I'm
eatin it
[Music]